The sauce. Kevin here,
please name one single object in this image.
Just one. This looks like a typewriter. Uh,
this is a blue blue balloon, some kind of chunky cream cheese.
And, uh, I don't even want to guess what that is. Yeah. This is impossible.
You can't accurately identify even one element of this photo.
A similar image went viral last year,
but don't feel bad that your brain can't make any sense of this image.
Neither can artificial intelligence, at least not yet.
Google cloud vision API says that this photo of Jake and I contains hats,
glasses, people, food.
The best it can do on this photo is packaged goods.
The image does,
however I promise contain real objects that are distorted by AI and
I'll reveal what they are a little later.
Our brains love identifying classifying and making sense of
meaningful inputs.
And without the ability to focus on meaningful information,
you're just confused.
I've been working with LG who sponsored this video on exactly what all this
means for technology in our everyday life.
We've never really been able to filter and prioritize audio visual
information until pretty recently. And until very recently,
it definitely hasn't been easy or affordable.
They sent me the new LG velvet.
So I can go over a real example of how tech has to be human focused
and work with our brains and explore how premium
technology is packed within devices accessible to more and
more people.
The democratization of technology is amazing,
but when you hear about pixel binning and audio Boca,
it's hard to get a sense of why it matters actually matters
to you. So here's a question, how are we exactly?
Does this phone take your picture?
Light reflects off a subject and into a lens which focuses it.
Then it's passed through a mosaic, filter an image sensor,
then through a digital converter where it's processed into what goes into the
memory. So, yeah,
it's a lot like what an eyeball does as it sends an image to your brain,
the larger that sensor,
the more information it's capturing and that's hard to achieve when a phone's
lens is tiny, a premium smartphone,
like the LG velvet uses pixel binning technology to overcome this hurdle.
Pixel binning sees data from four pixels and uses an algorithm to
combine them into a single more precise pixel.
Sometimes color information is pretty clear, but in low light shots,
you either need an exceptional sensor or a way to interpolate the visual
information, a quad Bayer filter. That's 50% green,
25% red and 25% blue creates an image in
RGB the same way your eye does so paired with the pixel binning algorithm.
You're able to take limited visual information and get a clearer brighter
photo.
The velvet further enhances camera performance with multi-image fusion,
which uses LGS proprietary algorithm to combine several images at
once. As it identifies and eliminates the unwanted noise in each one,
the images are then fused clearly,
which also highlights the most dynamic visual values.
And it just plain interprets visual data more clearly than we can.
The clearer, the picture,
the fewer cognitive biases creep in for our brains to see
what isn't there. The bokeh effect works similarly.
It's from the Japanese bulk,
meaning blur and it's that tasteful blur that minimizes what we don't want to
focus on and highlights what we really need to look at.
Do something for me. Hold your hand.
And out about 15 centimeters from your face,
then focus your eyes right on your Palm.
Everything in the background is blurred.
Now it's about playing with the depth of field and distance from the lens,
whether it's your eyes or your camera Boca happens when a large
aperture lens opens up and you can see the bulkhead effects develop as the
aperture gets broader.
Smartphones just do not have large sophisticated lenses with
easily varying apertures,
but a dual lens camera allows for one lens to focus on the image
and another to capture information like distance with information from both
the LG velvet can apply a Gaussian blur algorithm to the portion of the image
that should be out of focus. Vocab works great,
but it's actually really important,
too much information or irrelevant information is a cognitive
distraction from what we need to focus on.
When our eyes are distracted,
they tend to focus on what's closest to us.
No matter if it's what we should be paying attention to in 1960 J
Mandelbaum showed that the eyes of pilots and drivers fixated on the dirty parts
of a windshield instead of the full view of everything in front of them,
it's not an iron malfunction.
Oh, okay.
It's just your brain focusing on the wrong thing.
Like if my glasses are dirty,
I have to clean them immediately or it drives me insane.
That's me fighting the Mandelbaum effect,
Bo cat prioritizes, what we want to on.
So our brain doesn't have to fight itself to sort out
information. Audio Boca has the same effect,
but the technology is different rather than softening less
important pictures.
Audio vocab eliminates unwanted sound so you can hear
what you need to hear. Check it out. I'm outside right now,
where cars and construction and nature,
or all noise competing with my voice to get to your ears.
This is recorded in basic mode.
So you can hear what basic mode sounds like. This is voice bulkhead.
Now you're really just hearing my voice,
the meaningful thing that you want to hear when you're on the
phone, without that we're subject to what cognitive scientists,
Collin cherry called the cocktail party problem where the superior temporal
gyrus has to engage, to prioritize auditory information,
which makes it possible to hear a single conversation.
I didn't noisy cocktail party.
The velvet does this for you by breaking down sound frequencies
and using a series of algorithms to identify the subjects
voice. Then it's separated from all the other sounds,
being captured by using [inaudible] analysis.
The spectrum of tones that make up sound is mapped and processed to make a
sort of fingerprint of static noise than the lesser tones are
turns down your ears. Can't filter any of that,
especially not in real time.
You've got to deal with all the noise at once and use your mental energy to
focus on the parts you want to hear with audio bulk.
Cathy tech handles that for you and frees up your gray matter.
Now let's free up the confusion over the photo. From the beginning of the video,
I created this image with a tool that uses AI and machine learning to combine
and edit images.
Everything came from an original set of real images and it tracks the
movement of these images throughout the evolution of distortions and stores them
as genes. The genes for my image were a shopping basket, cauliflower,
necklace, school, bus, stethoscope, toy, shop syringe,
upright manhole cover, and grand piano.
The result of all that is a frustrating to look at mine,
bending pile of noise.
It's an exaggerated example of the noise problems.
Tech is tackling with amazing speed, precision and efficiency,
and it's increasingly available to more and more of us
every day. So yeah, when a new phone comes out,
it's easy to get wrapped up in how many megapixels the camera is and how much
storage it has,
but technology isn't actually about any of
that.
It's about whether the thing in our pocket interfaces with our
actual human existence in a way that does something
better than we can or takes pressure off our
bodies.
Technology was a word that was barely used in English until the second
industrial revolution. It just,
wasn't what we use to talk about innovations.
And throughout the 20th century technology increasingly described
machines that extended our capabilities and allowed us to do
more work. That's still true,
but it's more than that.
Now in his 1904 book,
the theory of business enterprise economists and sociologists Thorstein
Veblen theorized that social institutions determined how
technology was used in 2020,
the institution is you.
And as always, thanks for watching. I don't know. I did that.
[Inaudible].